[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette ville de
plaisir au centre commercial
mon grand plaisir ouvert fin 2020 il va
enfin accueillir son multiplexe ugc
aujourd'hui visite guidée pour cette
émission vont avec
m
[Musique]
et pour débuter cette visite nous sommes
avec l'architecte de ces lieux pierre
chican bonjour et merci de nous recevoir
un peu chez vous en faites que vous avez
conçu design et tout cet ensemble ce
n'est pas votre première réalisation
pour le gc vous avez cités vous avez le
ciné ciné-cité pardon merci vous avez
réalisé les halles également ici nous
sommes dans un centre commercial quel a
été votre inspiration votre ligne
directrice la directrice elle et elle et
elle est très claire c'est son de
réaliser des salles et plus confortable
possible dernière génération on va dire
mais ce sont aussi des salles surtout
assez sobre
c'est le choix du gc des salles ou qui
sont ressemble finalement le tout les
unes les autres avec bien sûr chacune
leur parquet les particularités
puisqu'elles sont des choses différentes
mais sinon c'est globalement toutes les
salles se valent entre guillemets on va
rapidement allé voir les salles et on va
en parler là déjà je regarde un petit
peu sur le mobilier on reste sur du
design plutôt moderne sur un accueil du
public qui se fait donc ici on est dans
le coeur de l'accueil mais le public qui
ressort ne se croisent pas voilà c'est
ça tout à fait on a on a dans un cinéma
de notre salle où est à plus de 1300
personnes en fait lors de deux séances
un petit peu
complète notamment les samedis soirs on
a
à coeur de pouvoir faire sortir les gens
indifféremment des accès pour éviter
d'avoir un influent trop important de
cinéma et pour pouvoir gérer entre
guillemets les spectateurs au mieux dans
ce dans ce lieu de culture
[Musique]
nous continuons donc sa déambulation
dans ce centre commercial mon grand
plaisir c'est un centre commercial ici
quand on conçoit un cinéma dans un
centre commercial il faut s'inclure dans
les contraintes aussi d'architecturé
peut-être un univers qui existent déjà
aussi oui plus ou moins nous cherchons à
recréer notre propre univers pour ces
salles de cinéma bien sûr puisqu'il y
avait ça va il s'agit avant tout d'un
cinéma ugc et pas d'un cinéma de fin qui
a ses spécificités propres et par
ailleurs le centre commercial nous livre
en général et un volume assez assez
basique on va dire et nous avons
l'obligation de réaliser des contres et
les contraintes de techniques de manière
à pouvoir aménager ses salles au mieux
notamment des salves radiner puisque ce
sont les salles
si les marques des cinémas qui doivent
être fortement gratiné et à ce sujet
nous avons été obligés donc de recréer
un niveau complémentaires en fait sur et
on l'a vu on est monté un petit peu l'un
c'est dire que marshall en fait
normalement mais sur une salade ce
niveau a été complètement réalisées par
nos propres aménagement de manière à
pouvoir recréer un gradinage
suffisamment important dans les salles
dans chacune des salles à l'exception de
la grande salle qui elle demandait
gradinage forme très très important et
pour lequel nous avons pu descendre sur
le niveau rez-de-chaussée du centre
commercial on va s'installer juste
devant une des affiches de films voilà
l'odyssée de l'espace
vous verrez sur les différentes images
le cinéma en mouvement c'est le thème
des différents quatre réalisations
affiches posters qui sont le long des
couloirs danse dans ce cinéma quand on
conçoit un cinéma aujourd'hui pour
sortir aussi peut-être un petit peu de
celui ci l'approché vraiment très
différente par rapport aux années 80
aujourd'hui on vient dans un lieu
vraiment de de loisirs en famille on
n'est plus vraiment même s'il existe
toujours dans les petits cinémas de
quartier il ya une approche vraiment
différente
oui c'est dur sur l aujourd'hui vraiment
il ya une approche différente lorsqu'on
a à coeur d'accueillir dernier un peu
mieux les spectateurs que dans les
années 80 ont leurs congénères des
espaces peut-être plus important au
niveau des foyers des déambulatoires
d'accès aux salles et on essaie de les
qualifier également c'est ce qu'on a
essayé de faire dans ce cinéma donc où
donc c'était obligatoire qui dessert
l'ensemble des salles d'une manière très
claire avec une signalétique assez forte
comme vous pouvez le voir et le voilà
donc tu t es on essaye de qualifier donc
on en a on a traité des l'ambulatoire en
mettant en place une espèce de galeries
portrait en fait de deux sur le thème du
cinéma en mouvement
peut-être votre sentiment aussi
j'imagine que le cinéma vous manque
je ne serai plus tous ces longs mois de
fermeture vous attendez vous imaginez le
public revenir en masse justement et pas
seulement ici pour découvrir forcément
ce lieu mais retourner dans les salles
cette démarche là oui j'en suis persuadé
oui rien ne rien ne pourra remplacer le
le partage collectif en fait d'un
spectacle ou d'un représentation ce pays
cinématographique d'un film en fait donc
non la salle on est on est honnête on
vit le film à plusieurs alors que chez
soi on le vit tout seul on va les
découvrir c'est ça justement rapide
membres allons-y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et nous découvrons à présent la plus
grande salle de ce multiplexe du cinéma
mon grand plaisir présentez-nous un
petit peu cette salle presque 400 places
c'est la plus grande donc salle du
complexe est une
c'est une constante dans les multiplexes
vous avez essentiellement souvent enfin
il faut enfin toujours en fait une la
plus grande capacité pour les films à
grand spectacle bien sûr pour les films
qui font beaucoup d'entrées et là où la
présence du public est importante pour
faire vibrer la salle donc à la normale
dans ce multiplex les autres salles
accueillent combien de spectacle la plus
petite 80 la moyenne 120 est la plus
grande et effectivement ça de la ou
390 avec un très grand écran puisqu'il
est il fait 18 mètres de l'argent je
vais pas je reviens sur l'une des
particularités vous nous avez parlé tout
à l'heure on est dans un centre
commercial normalement tout est situé
sur la même dalle et pourtant on a un
tas de décembre les marges de profit de
la carte
alors c'est l'exception qui ne confirme
pas la règle puisque cette salle est
déposé sur le au rez-de-chaussée et on a
profité donc d'une
tout l'auteur pour aménager les gradins
qui sont qui était nécessaire à cette
salle évidemment puisque on avoir à peu
près six mètres de dénivelé de gradins
face à cet écran qui est quand même
assez grand à ces gigantesques et vous
arrivez dans un cinéma comme celui ci
vous vous dites il faut que je réalise
la plus grande salle donc pour
accueillir vous commencez vous commencez
par quoi comme chaque détail compte
chaque détail compte il faut comme je
voulais dit la lune l'homogénéité des
salles est important pour gc c'est à
dire que la salle soit petit ou plus
grande une très grande
en fait le confort doit être le même
dans toutes les salles et le spectateur
de ce doit se retrouver finalement dans
les mêmes conditions à la taille de
l'écran près donc tout est au service de
l'image le la décoration est très sobre
et quand la lumière s'éteint en fait ne
compte que l'image à l'écran et avec
toutes les évolutions aussi
technologique est ce que ça remet
régulièrement en cause en est la façon
de travailler pour vous renouveler
régulièrement il faut rester à la pointe
des dernières innovations et s'adapter
aussi ou et ce alors essentiellement les
délais les dernières technologies en
fait ce sont les dernières évolutions du
cinéma seront technologique uniquement
et c'est pour ça qu'à ce titre nous
avons créé un concept de cinéma nous de
architectural en fait puisque ce
depuis les années 50 toutes les salles
se ressemblent plus ou moins et seule la
technologie changent le son l'image
et puis des d'autres investigations dans
des dents des demandes et présente les
salles qui avec des photos qui bouge
comme ça mais c'est assez rare finances
ici pas de salle qui bouge non on a
évoqué le cinéma des années 80 tout à
l'heure et des différentes évolutions
dans 20 ans le cinéma 30 ans vous
l'imaginez comment je n'imagine pas
encore je ne sais pas où malheureusement
c'est non si j y pense mais c'est
compliqué c'est difficile de savoir
comment on va déjà retrouvé le chemin
des salles et ce sera une bonne chose
merci beaucoup aux pierres chico donc de
nous avoir fait découvrir ce lieu cette
visite donc du cinéma mon grand plaisir
et nous allons nous rendre à présent en
coulisses pour découvrir à l'une des
cabines de projection sécurité incendie
climatisation plomberie ou encore
gestion technique la projection ne
représentent que 25% du métier
d'opérateur
c'est pourtant ce qui nous intrigue le
plus à savoir quel chemin fait un film
avant d'apparaître sur le grand écran
sur un disque dur qu'on à la maison
classique soit on reçoit pavia paraboles
donc pas satellite en dématérialisé ce
qu'on ressent par fibre contrairement à
ce que l'on pourrait penser le film ne
peut pas être visionnées avant le jour j
on peut pas diffuser directement comme
ça on a besoin d'une autorisation
diffusion du distributeur ce qu'on
appelle une ktm
enfin techniques clés de décryptage qui
perdent qui dit aux producteurs de thé
leur est tel jour à telle heure quinze
jours qui peut diffuser le film avant et
après on ne peut pas maintenant que
valve il ya donc
une fois qu'on a fait ça après on peut
lancer la science il n'y a pas de souci
reste enfin le dernier travail celui de
la projection
pour cela les cabines du nouveau cinéma
sont équipés de technologies avancées
toutes les cabines sont exactement
pareil ici sur ce nouveau cinéma une
équipe et en projecteur laser type
phosphore qu'une nouvelle génération
avec un refroidissement schiller qui
permet d'avoir une image on a vu on est
assez content du résultat pour le coup
par rapport à la taille d'écran la
distance de projection
on va pouvoir se faire des belles
séances et ces machines devraient
tourner à plein régime avec la pause
forcée du septième art 400 à 500 films
sont en attente de projection
[Musique]
un vrai plus pour nous puisque ça vient
compléter complètement l'offre qu'on
pouvait proposer ici à mon grand plaisir
puisque on avait déjà une belle offre de
commerces une très belle offre de
restauration aussi du loisir est donc
cette offre de loisirs culturels
finalement via complètement compléter
l'offre du centre
ça va être une seconde ouverture pour
nous puisqu'on avait fait la première
inauguration fin août dernier une
première inauguration qui s'était très
bien passé d'ailleurs
et puis on avait été un peu coupé dans
notre élan après les fêtes de fin
d'année puisque puisqu'on était fermé
depuis depuis le début février
comme la plupart des grands centres
commerciaux en france c'est vrai que ça
va être
c'est une reprise après plusieurs mois
de fermeture mais on a hâte parce que
vraiment on est prêt à accueillir les
gens dans toutes les normes sanitaires
en vigueur et puis avec beaucoup de
plaisir puisque on a profité aussi de
cette période de fermeture pour avoir
d'autres enseignes qui ont terminé leurs
travaux qui sont qui seront donc fait à
ouvrir comme j'essaie le cinéma va
rentrer dans le sens commercial et va
créer une vraie synergie avec le reste
du centre finalement puisque il vient
compléter cette offre qui était déjà
existante de commerces de loisirs de
restauration avec cette offre de loisirs
culturels donc forcément il va être
signée avec le centre avec un
fonctionnement forcément un petit peu en
décalage sur les horaires mais
finalement ça va former et évidemment un
tout pour que tout le monde vit bien
ensemble et que chacun ait son temps on
va dire dans la journée
[Musique]
et
mais ça y est on peut on peut chanter on
peut danser on peut tout en allant au
cinéma comme dans la fiche de la la land
qui est derrière nous je vous affirme
que le manx verger bonjour bonjour vous
êtes la mère de plaisir vous êtes aussi
la vice présidente du conseil
départemental en charge de la culture ça
tombe bien on va parler de cinéma du
mark allemand traverse bonjour vous êtes
donc le directeur de ce cinéma ugc
plaisir formidable de penser qu'on va
pouvoir rouvrir des cinémas un oui c'est
une
en tout cas ça sent bon c'est ce qu'on
peut dire on a entendu que vers le mois
de mai il ya des choses qui pouvaient
changer donc on espère je suis pas dire
de date ni rien du tout mais en tout cas
on espère véritablement puisqu'il est
prêt et puis toute façon cinéma et
plaisir ça va ensemble au mauvais jeu de
mots mais il ya beaucoup de choses qui
vont ensemble à être plaisir c'est
important pour une ville d'avoir un si
mal on va on va en parler avec mark
allemand b il il ya neuf sable enfin
donc c'est un cinéma très très important
c'est à dire que le plaisir a toujours
eu un cinéma tout petit lien avec deux
salles il ya de nombreuses années
et puis on a vraiment senti que quand
ces salles ont été fermées pour diverses
raisons commerciales en tout cas puisque
c'était un lieu qui appartenait à un
privé et qui a fermé on a senti à un
vrai besoin de la part de la population
pas uniquement plaisir oise mais même
des environs d'avoir un lieu
cinématographique donc l'opportunité a
été merveilleuse puisque quand ce ce
grand projet de centre commercial de mon
grand plaisir a commencé à naître avec
la compagnie de phalsbourg
eh bien j'avais tout de suite dit avec
même le maire qui m'a précédé monsieur
joël regnault on a tout de suite demandé
qu'il y ait un cinéma à l'intérieur de
ce grand centre et ça a été entendu ça
pas été si simple hein parce qu'il a
fallu quand même les gossier oui oui oui
parce que si vous voulez il ya de la
concurrence alentours et bien sûr quant
à nouveau centre cinématographique se
crée forcément ça crée des
problématiques et des interrogations
on y est arrivé grâce à la collaboration
avec ugc avec le département est
également avec les commissions qui sont
haddock par rapport à ces prises
décision et on a obtenu cette
possibilité de monter un cinéma de neuf
salles qui est finalement proportionnel
à ce que la ville est aujourd'hui on
disait complexe autrefois côté on était
complexe
non c'est vrai que c'est un taille
humaine et ça permet d'en parler avec
mark allemand de programmer beaucoup de
choses différentes
exactement d'avoir du choix d'avoir de
l'art et essai d'avoir de l'opéra mais
directeur en parlera mieux que moi mais
il est clair que ce qu'on voulait c'est
quelque chose de moyens dans sa taille
et en plus on a la chance que ce soit
intra muros c'est à dire au centre ville
a alors que très souvent les complexes
comme vous dites étaient faits en
périphérie est donc là on est dans un
centre-ville alors ça peut créer aussi
quelques interrogations sur le trafic
sur la circulation mais en même temps
c'est un centre ville c'est un cadre de
vie particulier on a tellement la chance
aussi d'avoir total espaces verts autour
avec des quartiers très calme donc ce
centre aujourd'hui cinématographique est
attendu véritablement et puis il est à
sa taille qui nous semble la plus à dock
pour présenter un maximum de choses à la
fois pour les enfants les adultes et les
mélomanes puisque comme je le disais
mais va aussi de l'opéra et j'en suis
ravi la marque allemande est justement
le disais on est on est dans ce centre
commercial de mon grand plaisir
vous êtes aussi le directeur de beauty
ni aussi dans un centre commercial
c'est important est ce que ça change un
peu le public qui va au cinéma
le fait d'être dans ces lieux là écoutez
ao je pense qu'aujourd'hui montini
plaisir on est dans la même
agglomération
on les sent un centre commercial cas
ouvert en septembre dernier qui est tout
neuf tout neuf mais moi je le trouve
super mais c'est vrai que on a dans
cette ville de plaisir j'en parlais
encore quelques instants avec madame la
maire on a une vie familiale
on a une ville attractive et je crois
que d'être dans cet environnement dans
ce centre commercial
oui ça va nous apporter mais au delà
j'espère qu'on va avoir beaucoup de
familles c'est vraiment la quintessence
même de saint quentin est d'avoir des
jeunes parents des familles etc
et je pense que notre cinéma est comme
vous le disiez
cher patrice ses neuf salles
correspondent exactement aux besoins du
gc et de plaisir donc c'est vrai que je
pense qu'on a un véritable écrin de
culture adossé à à l'espace coluche le
théâtre de la ville je pense qu'il ya
vraiment un superbe ensemble on parlait
de réouverture prochaine
voilà on sent qu'il ya une envie on ça
qui on sent qu'il ya une appétence par
ruse pour retrouver nos salles enfin
enfin oui et c'est vrai que vous avez
raison de le dire c'est sans doute le
cinéma le loisir le plus familial sans
doute le plus populaire aussi celui qui
au ch'ti qui est partagé par tout le
monde parce que tous les films certes
partout en même temps ces décès quand on
va au théâtre il faut aller à paris quoi
vous voir les pièces avons tourné au
delà
non c'est pas vrai ça c'est formidable
parce que sacré au fond un lien social
assez extraordinaire mais je crois que
le cinéma est comme vous le disiez à
l'instant vous avez dollar et c'est vous
avez des films et dans la bonne
connotation plus populaire plus avec des
films pour enfants
je crois que le cinéma est l'une des
rares cultures qui brasse toutes les
générations
toutes les catégories
socioprofessionnelles du plus petit à
trois ans jusqu'à la personne la plus
âgée
c'est quand même mais c'est quand même
plutôt des jeunes qui vont aussi
maintenant écoutez moi je
oui j'en il ya beaucoup de jeunes je
suis d'accord avec vous naturellement ça
va dépendre des films aux abonnés il ya
des films qui sont plus auteurs qui sont
plus regardés par les papes par d'autres
personnes
on a des films naturellement les dessins
animés c'est une grande majorité
d'enfants
bien que mal à ma mère l'a finie
confidences tout à l'heure quel adoré
les films pour enfants etc
oui donc c'est vrai que naturellement
pour moi le cinéma c'est un vrai
brassage dans toute sa grandeur dans
tout ce qui est beau voilà je trouve et
donc ça on a un véritable lieu de
culture à plaisir qui va ouvrir dans
quelques jours il ya une appétence du
plus petit au plus âgé
tout à l'heure je faisais visiter le
site tout le monde était émerveillé je
dirai pas ce que m'a dit vas y à ma mère
si je vais le dire waouh
quant à la visite et les séries je pense
que ces voix là il ya une véritable
attente il ya énormément de films qui
sont en attente pour retrouver leur
public
on va ressortir dans les prochains jours
et en voir parler des films qui sont
arrêtés quand on a refermé on va
regarder
4 il ya une véritable attente
moi le premier nous nous transcende qui
avons créé ce cinéma donc voilà j'espère
ça sera vraiment dans tout le temps dans
les tout prochains
il y avait une demande des habitants dit
qu'il y avait déjà un cinéma mais mais
d'avoir ou en effet quelque chose
peut-être de plus vastes avec ses 900
vraie attente on en entendait parler et
puis faut pas oublier que plaisir et
quand même une ville qui a vu naître
jean dujardin devrait et et guillaume
canet parce qu'ils sont les deux pays
roi et donc alors c'est pas pour ça que
les plaisirs sénat français actuel est
né à plaisir
je n'osais pas le dire je dis quand même
et donc c'est vrai que c'est c'est une
vraie attente et vous parliez d'âge
moi j'ai toute une série de personnes
âgées seniors qui aujourd'hui n'attend
que ça bien sûr on n'a rien à l'étude
même parler de la proportion c'est une
véritable attente parce que déjà comme
je le disais ça faisait partie un petit
peu de la vie ici de plaisir et puis à
plaisir on a eu depuis plusieurs années
un vrai regain culturel très très fort
on a remis en selle je dirais beaucoup
de choses merci d'avoir parlé du théâtre
mais c'est vrai que nous avons un
théâtre 2000 places et vous parliez de
spectacles parisiens on les fait venir
aujourd'hui on a une programmation
donc voilà il ya toute une synergie et
une une de nouveau une dynamique et mise
en place auprès de la population donc il
manquait plus que le cinéma donc
maintenant que le cinéma est là on va me
demander la piscine je pense un peu ça
c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans une ville
et oui oui la nôtre on veut tous on sait
que en tournée tout sur place alors on
en est bien sûr toujours sont attachés à
la villa où on est on est fier de tout
ça et puis en plus je veux dire ce
bâtiment est ce cinéma est vraiment
splendide donc ça valait vraiment la
peine qu'on se bat pour avoir ce cinéma
alors il va y avoir évidemment tout un
processus de reprise du cinéma avec des
jauges ça se passe comment vous vous
êtes déjà vous savez déjà comment ça ah
oui ça ça fait maintenant plusieurs
semaines que toute la fédération des
cinémas français travaillent à un
protocole avec le ministère etc
on en connaît maintenant les grandes
jauge dès que le président de la
république donnera son top départ mais
en tout cas dès qu'on aura le top départ
du président on pourra ouvrir avec des
conditions avec une jauge vous savez
qu'une capacité minimale en salle de 35%
pour faire très simple sur une salle de
100 personnes que 35 personnes seront
autorisées à rentrer en salle en
respectant toujours les distanciation
social ça veut dire être le nas avec le
masque obligatoire pendant toute la
séance d vous rentrez dans le cinéma
vous devrez avoir
masques naturellement il y aura dans les
salles si vous avez un conjoint des
enfants pourrait naturellement vous
mettre à côté mais à chaque fois vous
devrez laisser des espaces entre vous et
un groupe un autre groupe et respecter
une jauge de 35% à 37 % c'est une bonne
place sur 3 1
c'est à peu près ça exacto voilà donc
nokia normalement dans nos salons
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucun risque nous
avons la ventilation nous avons de
l'association sociale nous avons les
masses nous avons les gels on a tous à
aujourd'hui pour accueillir nos
spectateurs dans les meilleures
conditions
là-dessus je suis très serein et on
l'était même au moment de la fermeture
des cinémas aujourd'hui d'autant plus on
continue sur cette dynamique
hélas l'épidémie va pas s'arrêter demain
ou après demain
donc on aura toujours des gestes
barrières à respecter donc c'est vrai
que le protocole je vous parlais dans la
première étape
on sera à 35% de jauge et en fonction de
la situation il paie de maïs en france
dans l'axé nation qui va prendre de
l'ampleur
normalement trois à six semaines après
on pourra passer sur des jauges un peu
plus importante et donc ça je pense que
ça va scander les premières semaines de
notre l ouverture pour d'ici quelques
semaines ou un plus rapidement possible
pouvoir accueillir 100 % de spectateurs
alors il ya cette reprise et il ya deux
ans en entente de son cloche est un peu
différent il ya ceux qui disent ça va
voilà et c'est un peu la population qui
vous dit ça on a envie que ça reprenne
envie d'aller au cinéma et puis il y en
a d'autres qui sont plus sceptiques iv
mathieu kassovitz par exemple qui avait
dit le cinéma en salle c'est fini des
gens n'ont pas pu avoir envie d'aller en
salle ils vont ils vont rester chez eux
regarder à la télé ou ou en streaming en
fait c'est quel est votre sentiment
là-dessus je suis pas trop d'accord
parce que pour être en lien avec les
partenaires qui sont dans la culture
aujourd'hui quand j'y partenaires c'est
plutôt les artistes les associations les
théâtres aujourd'hui tout le monde
travaille c'est à dire que ils sont tous
dans cette attente
alors c'est vrai que les réseaux ont
permis justement d'avoir des liens
la population et ça ça a été très bien
heureusement qu'on avait ça mais je vois
qu'en tant que vice-présidente au
département en charge de la culture
on n'a pas lâché les artistes pendant
cette période il ya eu d accompagnement
et on a bien senti que l' envie de
retrouver le monde d'avant c'est à dire
les salles de cinéma mais aussi des
salles de spectacle et la possibilité
d'être en direct avec le public est bien
présente
donc on met bien sûr et puis de dire que
c'est terminé non non on va certainement
rajouté à tout cela et tout l'existant
que nous attendons bien sûr ces
possibilités de réseau et de streaming
et tout ce qui est aujourd'hui possible
ça sera un plus mais en tout cas ça va
pas supprimer les salles de spectacle
certainement pas là on le sent bien il
ya un frémissement très fort on
travaille sur des reprogrammations
partout dans le département
au niveau des spectacles et les artistes
sont en répétition ils sont là c'est
comme les si les films aujourd'hui sont
en attente dans le monde en parle mais
mais oui mais alors s'il ya des artistes
probablement céder spectre est ce qu'est
ce qu'ils vont avoir cette envie là
écoutez moi je jouis et les plateformes
de streaming pendant le confinement est
énormément fonctionné et c'est vrai mais
tout récemment j'ai discuté avec des
clients que je croisais à plaisir et à
montigny oui pendant le confinement on a
regardé des différentes plateformes
mais qu'est ce que le cinéma nous manque
mais là le streaming comme un puissant
mais l'émotion que vous retrouvez dans
une salle
vous l'avez pas il avait dans votre
canapé un mode audio le confort et puis
le lh quand même l'exact inverse et puis
c'est vrai qu'ils ont osé dire enfin ne
serait-ce que le partage aller voir un
film en prenois un film un peu comique
etc
si on rirait une autre c'est pas
partager partager un élan comique une
avec 400 personnes vous ne trouverez pas
cette ambiance devant votre canapé
devant de votre téléviseur donc je pense
qu'il ya une vraie appétence des gens à
revenir de nos salles alors oui il y
aura le streaming wii aura les séries
c'est évident mais je pense que tout ce
que l'on entend qu'est ce qu'ils ont
envie de faire si on réouvre courant mai
salle aller au restaurant et aller au
cinéma allez voir un théâtre ils disent
pas je vais rester devant ma télévision
à regarder une série dont le but en or
est là aujourd'hui les gens auront envie
de retourner dans des lieux de culture
et j'inclus la culture au sens large
aussi bien théâtres cinémas et autres je
crois qu'il est le véritable envie on a
des films pour répondre à tout le panel
de spectateurs qui veut retourner en
salle
donc moi je suis pas très inquiet et
tout l or de pardon lors de la visite il
ya des personnes qui visitent et sur son
assise dans une des salles et ils ont
dit enfin oui il m'a même pas seulement
il dit on n'a plus qu'une envie c'est de
l'image et on l'attend donc c'était très
beau d'intensité touchant même ça prouve
bien que on a besoin de se retrouver
tous ensemble vraiment alors comme comme
vous le disiez d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
les artistes au bout que travailler je
crois que là il ya quatre ou cinq cents
films inquiets qui attendent une sorte
de bouteilles à ce qu'ils fassent ce qui
va se produire
comment ça va se passer ça va être
répartie oui naturellement on voit pas
avoir 400 films d'un coup d'envoi de la
santé oms va sortir 50 une par semaine à
peu près quand on divise les quatre son
film par le nombre de semaines oui on
est à 40 50 films et c'est pas du tout
sur ce scénario là où on va aller où
naturellement je pense qu'il va y avoir
un échelonnement dans 2021 et 2022 pour
permettre à tous les films de sortir
d'être exploités dans de bonnes
conditions
et puis il va y avoir cette petite
phrase ou non de la reprise où je pense
qu'on va ressortir les films qu'on avait
arrêté un peu brouillon mais finalement
je prends je prends les ôter au mois de
mars a juste un an au mois d'octobre on
avait faire nous on avait fermé le 29
octobre
on l'avait sorti une semaine avant à
dieu oleko
céline que tout le monde attendait comme
les césar très clairement il avait fait
il a eu une semaine d'exploitation très
bien martial
c'était l'un de ses meilleurs démarrages
à la sortie de windows 8 devant elle
quand elle qui était compliqué donc très
clairement ce sont des films qu'on va
reprendre à l'ouverture donc là dessus
voilà je pense qu'on va re re programmer
des films qu'on avait dû stopper un peu
abruptement suite aux annonces
gouvernementales on va les remettre et
les reprogrammer sur les premières
semaines de réouverture et après les
sorties classiques vont s'enchaîner
tranquillement mais il va pas y avoir un
embouteillage voilà ça va se faire dans
le temps pour permettre à tout le monde
de s'exprimer et de pouvoir venir dans
nos salles
regardez tout ce qui nous attend et tout
ce qu'on a à proposer à nos clients
alors neuf salles c'est vrai que dans la
période qui va qui va suivre la
rouverture évidemment ça va permettre de
diffuser la plupart des films qui
sortent mais à terre parce que ça permet
aussi d'avoir d'autres choix peut-être
j'ai pas des rediffusions de films
classiques des choses comme ça alors
nous on fait le choix je suis les océans
quand vous voyez parfois vous avez un
numéro 2 qui sort on essaye toujours de
programmes et de reprogrammer le numéro
un
les as exactement parce que je pense que
c'est un véritable plaisir de retrouver
des films et puis nous laisser nous
avons fait aussi le choix du du
complément aux films notamment nous
avons un partenariat qui ravit madame la
maire avec l'opéra l'opéra de paris
oui où dès septembre on proposera aux
habitants de plaisir la première saison
2021 2022 avec une vingtaine
d'opérateurs ont normalement une petite
dizaine en direct avec eux d'autres
partenariats de l'opéra de paris
donc ça dès septembre vous pourrez venir
à l'ugc plaisir vous serez la première à
voir cet opéra que naturellement il
attendait avec impatience
voilà ça sera diffusée dans nos salles
comme dans celle notamment de montigny
mais voilà on a un véritable choix de
films de ce qu'on peut appeler dur film
avec de l'opéra quelque chose très
qualitatif qu'on a envie de présenter
notamment
aux habitants que les ir alors on parler
d'adieux l'écho vous avez comme ça une
idée des démos four des grandes attentes
au des films qui vont sortir je vais pas
tout ce bruit sinon parce qu il y en a
plus de 400 m haies n'a que lyon était
reporté une autre dans ce conte
d'attentes plus soin par exemple témoin
je sais que là il ya des grosses
attentes notamment sur le dernier james
bond ou savez un an et demi qu'on
l'attend qui j'espère sera programmée en
en octobre prochain
donc il ya toutes ces séries là
notamment parlé aussi de tous les films
pour enfants il ya toute une série de
films pour enfants qui sont prévues pour
l'été
donc voilà il ya une véritable attente
et il y en aura pour tous les publics
donc ça c'est ça l'important
les enfants portent des noeuds fans ça
me permet simple s'il avantage qui va
gérer mais en même temps il y aura le
choix et oss 117 non non je crois qu'on
fera quelque chose ensemble
si vous avez un film de chevet quand
vous dire que pour toi des livres de
chevet en fait que vous aimerez
peut-être vous me demandez de leur
programme est comme ça alors moi il ya
un film qui me touche énormément pour
plein de raisons
c'est la vita è bella de béni oui la vie
est belle c'est tard c'est quelque chose
de très touchant
j'aime beaucoup le personnage et le
personnage vous souvenez l'art visant sa
gamme
oui il est vraiment formidable donc ça
c'est un film que j'aime beaucoup et on
se recale bon alors moi je suis ton même
registre mais j'aimerais faire un petit
clin d'oeil notamment que vous verrez
dans cinéma c'est la fiche qui est juste
devant moi et que vous verrez en début
la scion sur le film flashdance parce
que on a fait un thème dans le cinéma de
grandes affiches de cinéma en mouvement
et pourquoi cette affiche me veut
marquer marquer ce film c'est le premier
film que je voulais voir seul quand
j'étais début d'adolescence ça je m'en
souviens très bien c'était au cirano à
versailles et c'est vrai que c est quand
je regarde cette affiche était le
premier film qui m'a marqué parce que
c'est le premier que j'ai été voir seul
avec deux amis voilà comment lui doivent
donc c'est des films qui marquent et
donc voila quand vous diffuserez les
images vos téléspectateurs pour voir une
image de 2,2 ce film dans le cinéma
donc c'est vrai que c'est n'a rien à
voir avec bellini etc mais mes fait
ricco c'est un film qui me touche pour
différentes raisons plutôt sentimental
plutôt lié à mes premiers actes dans le
cinéma mais voilà donc n'hésitez pas
venez voir quand vous viendrez dans ce
dans ce cinéma là plaisir vous verrez
les affirme affiche notamment celle de
flashdance et celle qui est là pour face
à côté nous de la la land vous disiez
asie j étais ça me rappelle la phase de
croissance mondiale est requise et que
le cinéma c'est le la meilleure
invention qui nous permet de rester seul
dans le noir pendant une heure et demie
est-ce qu'ils n'étaient pas seuls voilà
c'est une image voilà qui restera à
jamais et quand je vois cette image
devant moi c'est vrai que c'est fait
quelque chose ça fait plein d'émotions
mon premier souvenir de cinéma au
contraire si la peur parce que je crois
que quand vous m'avez emmené au cinéma
peut-être un peu trop jeune et il y
avait eu il y avait eu des bruits
tellement fort et quand vous rentrez
dans une salle du cinéma il fait noir on
vous y préparer suffisamment
et bien moi je me rappelle avoir pris la
veste de
personnes qui étaient à côté de lui très
bien il avait misé sur la tête et
j'avais eu très très peur donc pas un
très bon souvenir
mais après on est attiré par la peur
irrationnelle
est-ce que mais une question plus
générale donc ça vient d'être construit
et conçu et construit est ce contexte où
les grands changements dans la
conception des salles de cinéma alors il
n'ya pas de révolution dans nos salles
de cinéma vous avez des sales
extrêmement moderne où la six
vous avez une excellente assise avec nos
fauteuils etc nous dans nos cabines tous
les projets tous les projecteurs seront
au laser avec un sont naturellement dans
les dernières technologies et vous avez
une petite spécificité a usé ses
plaisirs ou dans deux salles nous avons
équipé nos salons fait un va et c'est
2-2 réhausseur pour enfants d'habitude
c'est vrai si on a quelqu'un à grande
allure intégré donc c'est vrai que quand
on arrivait dans nos salles de cinéma on
était un blouson mettait pour que les
plus petits d'entre nous puisse accéder
à l'écran là on a fait le choix de
mettre dans le fauteuil à réhausseur qui
permettent aux enfants
quelle que soit la situation du grand et
du petit devant lui lui de pouvoir
mais l'addition spectacle donc voilà
donc on a fait une petite anecdote mais
je pense que c'est un vrai plus pour les
plus petits d'entre nous qui vont
pouvoir regarder en pleine sérénité ce
film réhaussé à la bonne hauteur
voilà je pense que qu'est-ce qu'on a
hâte d'ouvrir patrice et puis voilà on
croise les doigts pour se dire que quand
ça va ouvrir sa marester ouvert
exact respect merci là c'est un fils est
mort c'est une calebasse vers des
marques amora m'aide beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la fin de ce numéro de projet de
ville consacrée à l'ugc de plaisir
maintenant que les salles vont rouvrir
le choix ne devrait pas manquer ici
quant à nous on se retrouve bientôt sur
tv 78 la très bonne séance
[Musique]